marie-guite dufay on a interrogé
beaucoup sur la jeunesse en fait on se
renvoie des on nous renvoie des réponses
sur la sécurité comment vous réagissez à
savon et notamment aux critiques qui ont
été faites à la majorité sortante soit
la sécurité dans les lycées comme dans
les transports vers les deux compétences
de la région où effectivement nous
sommes légitimes à intervenir en matière
de sécurité
nous faisons le nécessaire et dans les
lycées nous avons un plan sécurité
n'en déplaise à monsieur platret il le
sait nous avons voté à bhl nous avons
voté un plan sécurité qu'ils ne trouvent
pas suffisant néanmoins nous l'avons
travailler avec les proviseurs et donc
nous avons nous n'avons absolument pas
mis de côté cette dimension ce serait
irresponsable
nous l'avons fait mais je pense qu'il y
à aussi à travailler de façon plus
culturelle sur la question de la
délinquance il ya deux façons de
travailler sur la délinquance et sur
l'insécurité il ya la façon sécuritaire
il ya la façon culturelle et c'est vrai
que tout à l'heure monsieur roudoule a
parlé des crédits que nous avons mis sur
les quartiers politique de la ville nous
avons mis beaucoup de crédit
qu'est-ce qui se passerait si nous
n'avions pas mis ces crédits en
direction des associations d'éducation
populaire des actions culturelles des
actions des associations qui travaillent
sur l'emploi des jeunes il y a encore
beaucoup à faire et sur baume les dames
oui dix fois oui il faut que le lycée
professionnel de baume-les-dames
s'élargissent à plus de matières
générales pour devenir un vrai lycées
d'enseignement général parce qu'on est
sur une zone en pleine dynamique en
pleine croissance et cela nous le
travaillons gilles platret faut-il aller
plus loin que ce qu'a fait la gauche en
termes de sécurité
c'est bien simple la sécurité a été son
angle mort c'est pour ça qu'il faut
l'alternance notamment jeune mouna là
c'est pas la compétence première les
régions est ce que c'est une compétence
que les régions n'ont pas le droit
d'exercer la réponse est non la culture
non plus n'est pas une compétence
première qui souhaiteraient aujourd'hui
revenir sur les enjeux culturels dans la
région belles compétences nos concret
bien entendu une nouvelle compétence sur
la sécurité
l'exemple des lycées est flagrant je
suis maire je sais pas monsieur turnhout
huriaux doit pas savoir que super de
chalon dont je lui
je suis mère aussi n'est pas le seul ici
mais en tout état de cause non parce que
nous on s'est partagé le pouvoir plutôt
bien ils vont marquer lorsque j'ai
étendu un système de vidéoprotection au
profit des habitants de chalon sur saône
nous avons su nous avons vidéo protéger
toutes les écoles notamment de chalon et
créer un système c'est 250 caméras le
département de saône et loire nous a
aidés à vidéo protéger les collèges la
région obstinément et madame du fait la
première à refuser la vidéo protection
des lycées
c'est une faute aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans une période d'insécurité enfants et
par conséquent est par contre je vais
jusqu'au bout même plus facile nous le
permettait et par conséquent demain nous
irons sur ces enjeux là c'est pas faire
du catastrophisme c'est simplement par
la sécurisation de protéger la liberté
de chacun quand on aura compris que la
sécurité n'est ni de droite ni de gauche
mais quand l'assuré on assure la liberté
alors je pense qu'on aura communément
fait un grand pas stéphanie modde je
vous voyais à fait ravi ainsi volontiers
parce que pour moi effectivement
entendre parler de la genèse comme
délinquance entendent parler de
vidéoprotection ce que demandent nos
jeunes skiff subissent actuellement leur
insécurité c'est leur insécurité de leur
avenir qui souhaite aujourd'hui c'est
pouvoir sortir de nouveau c'est pouvoir
refaire du sport faire des activités
culturelles sportives
voilà donc c'est ça vraiment intéressant
l'intérêt donc c'est aussi remettre de
l'humain parce que effectivement les
services publics ont été mis à mal
encore une fois dans les lycées nous
intervenons sur le bâtiment mais pas sur
le personnel pas tout sur les personnels
donc c'est remettre aussi de l'humain
dont nous lycée c'est permettre
effectivement aux jeunes des quartiers
défavorisés qui sont souvent stigmatisés
d'avoir la même chose que les autres de
même que des jeunes en milieu très
rurale on voit qu'à une différence
effectivement la région a des atouts et
la nécessité de donner la même chance à
l'ensemble des jeunes là où ils habitent
et pour finir sur les lycées il ya aussi
un besoin autour de sens parce qu'alice
a senti un énorme lycée 2500 élèves je
pense qu'effectivement il faut des
lycées aussi à plus à taille humaine et
donc se pose aussi la réflexion et nous
nous proposons la réflexion autour de la
construction d'un nouveau lycée vers
sens julien ont doublé ce que vous voyez
la jeunesse seulement comme la
délinquance je vais répondre à mme dufay
sur les compétences de la région
la santé initialement n'était pas une
compétence régionale ça l'est devenu
avec la crise sanitaire et c'est une
bonne chose
la région a notamment passé des
commandes de masques la région a investi
pour équiper l'hôpital public
millions d'euros la région a même acheté
une machine à masquer est-ce que ça
choque quelqu'un que l'accent titre
devenue une compétence non aujourd'hui
la sécurité des biens et des personnes
est une priorité une impérieuse priorité
est encore une fois aucune collectivité
ne peut s'en exonérer
alors moi je suis assez stupéfait de
voir que certaines personnes certains
responsables politiques considèrent que
la sécurité de nos concitoyens ne les
regarde pas moi la sécurité voyez c'est
ce dont on parle en priorité parce que
clairement aujourd'hui dans l'espace
public que ce soit dans les transports
dans les gares que ce soit même pour
aller au travail
aujourd'hui il ya une insécurité qui est
galopante et sur les crédits qui ont été
rapidement sur les critiques qui ont été
affectés à la politique de la ville
parce que c'est important
madame du fait nous dit finalement qu'il
faut mettre plus d'argent plus d'argent
pour éteindre l'incendié
alors que les quartiers aujourd'hui de
la région bourgogne franche comté qui
ont reçu le plus d'argent public c'est à
dire sur les cinq années un demi
milliard d'euros si on prend les cinq
quartiers les plus dangereux qui sont
notamment comme le quartier de ma ville
de sens des chaillots où des émeutes
urbaines ont eu lieu il ya deux jours
sont des quartiers les plus riches
moi je souhaite responsabilités et
arrêter tout simplement de verser de
l'argent pour alimenter la délinquance
mais